morning reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch the
official trailer for Aladdin I'm excited
to check this out I'm sure Disney is
going man that first looked it and go
down so well with the genie we need to
do some course correction and damage
control and usually course correction is
righted with my eyes before we go into
that I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who's been following us over at
our patreon page and first off if you
don't want to follow us on our patreon
page there are plenty of youtubers out
there who could use your support so if
there's a YouTube channel that you
consider to be your favorite and they
happen to have a patreon page
go show your support follow them on
patreon at our patreon we have weekly
Q&A s as well as TV show reactions
stream along for several shows that
includes one punch man my hero academia
did all of attack on titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood at Johnston most
of Riverdale the haunting of Hill House
Gotham and supernatural there are
several shows that actually have
reaction highlights with footage
included that's includes my hero
academia supernatural one punch man and
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood as of
late John also does plenty of music
video coverage so would love it if you
guys can go follow us over at our
patreon page but like I said if not us
choose someone else that you guys really
love not Tyrone totally not Sara
paramagnetism 1 million five do Tyrone
[Music]
horrorcore Aladdin
[Applause]
[Music]
I can make you rich princess
[Music]
like that's a lot better
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey they got dusted at the end they add
dust it's just a Disney effect now man
just the Disney effect now I mean the
production alone looks good that's the
best trailer they've had so far yeah
yeah well trailer it's by far the best
that the genius genie looks better than
before they they seem like they've
really improved upon the effects even
even in the what he's they're out in the
desert and it's bright yeah because it
seemed like last time with that first
look they tried masking it by making it
really target did not help yeah and I
actually kind of get what Will Smith is
going for here this time around
I mean when they started never had a
friend like me when they did that part
well well they I'm curious to know how
audience is gonna react to that because
it's Robin Willie comes it's a big song
and it doesn't even sound like he was
really singing it
you know I'm not like he was just saying
it you know yeah yeah you never had a
friend like me doing that kind of half
spoken half son thing but I don't know I
mean I fully expected to hear that song
and kind of reimagine for this so I'm
not mad about it and yeah I mean he
looks yeah I mean just the the whole
look of the world and all the beautiful
colors and stuff like that and seeing
the way they're transcribing this story
I mean it looks like a decently faithful
adaptation you know well I haven't seen
a ladder in a few years I don't I
remember Robin Williams Jeanie it was
you know very funny and often pushed
Aladdin into stuff and motivated him
yeah along with Abu and carpet yeah but
it seems like here the genie position is
much more of developing this best friend
slash much bigger motivator for Aladdin
yeah he's there seems to be some slight
tweaks here in the story it doesn't look
like oh it's only a shot-for-shot remake
there were elements there are images
plenty here and jokes and moments that
I'm like oh this is definitely not in
the original it's more than just a copy
of pace and bring it to live-action oh
yeah I would definitely imagine I mean
especially with the genie they're
probably gonna take this license to do
their own bits and let Will Smith walk
around and do his thing and stuff like
that but yeah especially the human form
version of the genie
kind of reminded me of Will Smith in the
Legend of Bagger Vance positions sort of
reminded me of that and hearing the the
guy who plays one and I don't know the
actor's name it's it's funny they got
all this a multiracial casting in here
which is really cool and everyone sounds
super American least have like an accent
or something yeah but everyone sounds
super American here well you know
probably everybody can't do the same
accents and I also like the element of
fantasy like that was something I was
wondering about with the genie and I
assumed that they would go fantastical
but you know you guys like
giant ham doing the puppet bit and that
makes me a further excited for the genie
especially on the heels of the
controversy from last time because that
you know that's a huge part of the
animation fun in the original movie is
those kind of moments yes sure the dance
sequences look fun I wanted to get a
little bit more of two different take on
Jasmine this time around because the
actress herself specifically stated that
they were gonna do more with her and
make her more than just someone who's
you know like I don't want to have to
marry a prince even though I know that
elements gonna be in here they even cast
someone who's gonna be I think someone
who she's gonna be sort of pressured
into marrying yeah not more than just
like I want to marry who I want to marry
they wanted to add more depth to her I'm
feeling a strong female character here
but I'm not really gonna have a bunch of
like parkour and hand-to-hand combat
yeah lighting does parkour and this
breaks which makes sense actually gonna
end with them doing parkour side-by-side
and then when they do something it's
gonna freeze frame some of the action
scenes in here were like okay that's the
Guy Ritchie touch yeah here you know the
like all the chase sequences and the
explosions and stuff like that with the
giant bird I'm imagining that giant bird
moment is probably is that like Iago is
that after when Jafar gets he's full
star becomes the evil genie the evil
sorcerer I imagine that's when he does
that yeah he is because he become before
the evil genie yeah because the genes
were traps in what if that's what
they're gonna do the same thing here for
the way to beat him but indeed I don't
think he all goes voiced in this one
no it's still Gilbert Godfrey yeah he
was lying when he said he wasn't asked
to come back then we have be a pretty
cool element actually I guess he was
kind of here they hint at Rajan here and
but that and the whole the whole new
world sequence looks cool you know yes
nostalgic moments in here I mean
especially the stuff that you recognize
from the cartoon looks like it's been
transcribed with love especially in a
lot of these like wide establishing show
some just like let's drink in the beauty
of you know us translating this to
live-action it's kind of a part of every
one of these adaptations yeah you know
I'm actually I'm pretty satisfied with
the trailer yeah because it doesn't just
seem like chakra shot remake like you
got a lot of that there but she also got
plenty of new moments in here as well
and I'm actually liking the overall
dynamic between Genie and Aladdin still
not 100% so loaded but I'm liking it and
the effects they definitely did
course-correct there yeah I mean I'm
still curious about the choice to have
to make this guy ritchie's Aladdin
basically I'm still kind of waiting for
the movie to prove to me why he was the
best choice for this but as that stands
yeah I mean this is a pretty solid
trailer I mean I love the colors and the
production designed and the things that
hearken back to what I remember from the
original some of the things that look a
little new cautiously optimistic and
before I wrap this video up of Alexi
have a page in the day shout out to a
wonderful woman named Jenna Randolph
Jenna is a woman who's been a part of
our patreon page for a few months now
and you know what it's her birthday next
week so I wanted to say happy early
birthday to ya I will show you the world
shining shimmering splendid by taking
you to Google I I'm not gonna go to
where you live everything's on Google
everything's on Google and I go like an
online shopping day why would I so much
easier that way like Skype call so I do
my days of my girlfriend yeah why go to
Disneyland well we could just look at it
on Google Maps listen Jenna I know you
had some issues with you know getting a
dog and then get to return the dog I
know it could be a kind of a rough
period I've been through tough times
like that before but just know that
everything's gonna be okay and I know
you were thinking about taking the trip
to Chicago for your birthday and I say
go do it go party don't get a deep-dish
pizza dude that's the best way to do it
and get some deep-dish other deed that I
won't say for this video cuz kids might
be watching yeah deep deep it's me yeah
extra sausage double d double meat pizza
we're talking only about leads our kids
yeah only pizza just like a really yeah
you enjoy yourself
decadent pizza happy early birthday you
beautiful girl you guys you cannot
reject nation click the notification
bell and check us on patreon yep